hello everyone
i've been receiving a number of requests
for making a video about undergraduate
research now this is a topic which is
very very close to my heart because
every academic year i spend a
considerable amount of time mentoring
undergraduate students
for their undergraduate dissertation
or some kind of project so
i think i'm in a good position to share
a few tips with you and
i thought that if you just generally
search on the internet you will find
lots of tips for research at the phd
level or even at the master's level but
there's not much tips uh going around
for the undergraduate students
and certainly there's not much on
youtube also
so i think this is going to be really
helpful to you uh so without further ado
let's get into this
uh before i actually share the tips i
would like to say that there are certain
challenges uh
associated with undergraduate research
which are probably not there at the phd
level so you have to keep those things
in mind and i will make it a point to
share those things with you in this
video
okay so uh
before we can actually jump into the
research part you have to understand a
few things
uh
first of all you have to understand the
mentality of the professors with whom
you are going to work with okay so
suppose you want to approach a professor
please do not ask uh to do a project for
a very short duration like six months so
at the the undergraduate
time scale six months is a lot of time
it's more than an actual semester but
understand that at the at the time scale
of research activities six months is
nothing okay so if you have to achieve
something substantial it has to be
significantly more than that and no
professor would be interested in or very
rarely a professor would be interested
in
working with you
on such a short-term project okay
now another thing is that
okay let's be let's be honest about it
let's call a spade what it is
uh
you see
uh whenever you whenever you are going
to work with a professor
as an undergraduate student
you have to appreciate that there is a
selfish interest associated with the
professor also okay because
uh
why would he ever invest his time
on
introducing use to research if he's not
getting anything out of it it may sound
like very business-like and commercial
kind of enterprise
it's not actually that okay try to
appreciate the thing a little bit his
main priorities are teaching and
supervision of phd students and if
possible supervision of post docs
now
when he has to spend his time with an
undergraduate student he has to actually
introduce him to many things
and
help him to learn the ropes of the trade
the tricks of the trade
so there's a considerable time
investment involved and
i guarantee you this
most of the professors they enjoy doing
this okay given infinite amount of time
but
ah
their time is not infinite okay so
they'd be rather doing something else
like teaching
supervision of phd students
writing up papers writing up books
writing up very importantly funding
proposals
and
making youtube videos
okay jokes apart uh let's get in
the business and of things you see
uh as i was saying uh there's a selfish
interest of the professor what is that
so when he's working with you he
actually wants to get something out of
it which will be of symbiotic
beneficial value to you also as an
undergraduate student so what is that so
uh
maybe you get to write a paper
okay now that would be the pinnacle of
achievement or maybe you uh you get to
get a get a patent out of some kind of a
product that you develop or maybe some
kind of methodology you develop or maybe
some software also that you develop
working with the professor so these are
some certain tangible output outcomes uh
which if you put in the effort and show
that you are really interested in doing
those kinds of things the professor will
be really interested
sometimes what happens is that uh at the
undergraduate level it may not be
possible to
do that kind of a full-fledged research
uh what the professor will do then is
that he out of a larger project of a of
a of a product development or some kind
of a scientific individual he will share
with you only a small part of it
on which if you work maybe along with
another phd student there will be
certain substantial outcome okay so the
professor would be very much interested
in in doing that kind of a work with you
also
there's another kind of work uh
which is actually very interesting so
sometimes what happens is that uh
a professor is trying to get into a new
line of research
now that's a risky business okay so uh
a high-stakes kind of thing like a phd
that those kinds of problems in an
absolutely new area may not always be
given to a phd student okay because his
career is at stake directly his career
is at stake because of
of the extreme time constraints of a phd
however
uh an undergraduate student
uh his uh
uh i mean his degree is directly not may
not be associated with that project work
okay i'm not talking about the actual
btec project or the dual degree project
the students have to do here so maybe
some kind of a project that the student
is doing out of his own interest
that kind of a situation is ideal for
the professor to share his absolutely
new research idea or history into a new
research direction with okay so that can
be really extra exciting work for you as
well as with the professor and i find
that no matter what the age of the
professor professor is he'll be really
enthusiastic to work with you in those
kinds of things
okay
so this is about uh
before you actually launch into the
thing what are the things to keep in
mind but once you actually get the
project uh once you start working with
the professor invariably what will
happen is that he will share uh some
kind of
preliminary study material for you with
your preparatory material i'm not
talking about uh the the actual uh
primary references that he'll ask you to
read up on rather some kind of very
like zeroth level kind of study material
and preparatory material so once you get
that
i mean
launch yourself heart and soul into
reading up that stuff and this is very
exciting work very everything is new and
shiny
i mean
it's it's really nice
but this enthusiasm often doesn't last
too long for many students
well what happens is that after the the
initial enthusiasm has died off they
realize that they have to actually read
up stuff and when they start reading
they realize that practically they don't
know much
okay
actually they don't know much
and
sometimes they feel very flustered
very demotivated that what i mean they
have been working so hard at their
coursework and uh
so what is the end result of this that
they take up a study material and they
can't understand even the basics of it
what's going on so please do not feel
bad about it okay it has happened to the
best of us and even now when i go into
some new kind of research area it
happens to me i pick up some basic study
material i don't understand uh even the
beginning parts of it okay it is
supposed to be this way don't feel bad
about it just keep at it with a little
bit of patience and persistence it will
sort yourself itself out okay you have
to have a little bit of patience and the
most important thing in research work is
courage okay so you have to have the
courage all right
now
uh
there is an opposite end of the spectrum
or or the or the process to it here also
what happens sometimes is that
certain students have an extremely
scholarly bent of mind and whenever they
get some new study material they are
tremendously pumped up and they launched
themselves really hurt and soul into it
in fact they do it so much that it is to
the detriment of the actual curriculum
work you have to understand that this
project work is your side business your
actual thing your actual
is to maintain your grade points in your
actual curriculum you cannot cannot
neglect that okay now let's say there is
another uh scenario where the
student is not meet uh is not neglecting
his study work his actual studies the
curriculum work and is also maintaining
a good reading
routine with his project work in the
initial days now
all that is fine but even this can be a
little bit dangerous you've done too
much like reading is necessary but far
from sufficient you see the whole point
of uh of i mean when a professor shares
with you the study material the
preparatory material is that so that
your level is upgraded to a point where
you can actually start with the actual
project work and for that you just i
mean you can't just stop at the reading
or if you just keep on doing the reading
that's not enough so you have to
actually develop the requisite uh skill
sets so what are the skill sets
um
because if you
if you don't develop the skill sets
effectively you have not progressed i
mean you may have gained a lot of
knowledge but if you can't do anything
with that knowledge with some proper
skills
what good is it okay you have to
understand this okay so there has to be
some actionable progress all right so
what are the skill sets that you can
develop in this initial phase
well if it is a computational kind of
work then
you can develop some kind of or i mean
certainly your professor will ask you to
do this but i'm just giving some
examples like you can learn some coding
methods uh to code up some numerical
methods which are used for solving
various kinds of partial differential
equations absolutely important in
combinational work
or maybe you will get to learn some kind
of image processing which are important
in physics electronics
and
certainly in the
in the mechanical sciences also
or
maybe
you have to learn
some kind of new mathematical techniques
for example if you're doing a kind of
project which is
heavy on the mathematical modeling and
has a big flavor of the applied
mathematics side then
uh maybe you have to learn something
like asymptotic methods or maybe you
have to really really be good with uh
fourier transforms and laplace
transforms and so these are like some
general things which you may have to
pick up maybe some things related to
complex analysis okay and i'm not just
talking about people from the
mathematics department even
mechanical civil chemical aerospace
people they have to pick up these things
okay
now
uh
and this this can also be very exciting
uh thing but there is a danger even to
this
so what is the danger
you see once you start learning this
kind of new skill set uh there are lots
of tutorials lots of books and resources
available on the internet itself lots of
innumerable video lectures and what not
uh available to you okay like you are
living in the golden age of information
availability
so you probably can
do this a little bit too much meaning
that if you if your professor has asked
you to pick up a certain skill set maybe
let's say let's take for example coding
okay maybe you're learning to do
something in matlab and python that's
what that's what the platform has been
chosen for you uh and you are starting
to learn this
now
uh you can spend entire years learning
just the thing in all its generating but
you really think that is necessary for
your project maybe you need only a small
subset of the skill set there you don't
need to learn the whole of matlab you
don't need to learn the whole of python
okay nobody can do that but i mean i'm
talking about a large chunk of it so try
to pick what you need and then try to
get
uh ready for your actual project work as
soon as possible because time is of
premium
all right
next
uh another important thing okay another
danger so uh
as far as skill sets are concerned one
important skill sets many attempts uh
which you'll be asked to pick up is
learning some kind of commercial
software or maybe it's a it's a free and
open source software but some kind of
package okay maybe some kind of finite
element package
and there are lots of them out there so
when you start learning these things
these have reached such a good level of
maturity that
people
without proper background can actually
run this software and uh get some
beautiful plots like red blue green
yellow plots look very beautiful it
gives a certain satisfaction to you uh
it makes it feel apparently very
productive once you start doing those
tutorials of the software
but
i always caution this
when you're doing uh when you're using
such a software are you really aware of
the back end which lies at the uh or or
the fundamentals
which are at the back end of that
software i've seen certain students who
run these kinds of commercial packages
and they don't even know that finite
element methods has been used at the
back end
i mean what is going on
don't do this okay sometimes i mean what
happens is that they they are running
simulations they are getting plots but
at the end of the day if i ask them okay
tell me what are the partial
differential equations which are being
solved for for for solving this solid
mechanics problem or the speed mechanics
problem or this heat transfer problem
no answer i don't know
okay so this is very bad so please
please please do not do this okay please
do not do this i warn you and i request
you
okay
next uh
we have to come to the actual project
work so okay let's say that you have
done your uh your initial preparatory
work study work skill sets have been
developed
oh by the way i forgot
there are certain ancillary skills
that's also that you have to develop
okay as in in these initial days so
if you just keep on working and you
can't report what you are doing then it
is not of much value so a very very
crucial aspect of your project work and
this learning to do research is
developing these ancillary skill sets
what are these answering skill sets like
report writing like making publication
quality figures
okay so uh i mean this is such a huge
topic and on this you will find
innumerable videos and maybe if i get
the time and
the tempo to do this i will make some
videos myself
i did make one video regarding uh the
use of latex to create uh the citation
list so
anyway uh so you have to
develop these ancillary skill sets also
okay
and there are a number of free and open
source software uh to
to explore to learn and that's can that
can be actually fun okay uh so
maybe instead of
watching too much netflix uh and
spending too much time on youtube
watching this and that maybe a little
bit of time can be invested on learning
that also and actually on youtube there
are some great tutorials to learn those
things also
all right uh so once the actual project
starts okay so what will usually happen
is that your professor will share one or
two papers with you papers means
scientific papers uh
technical papers
as your primary references you're
supposed to study them understand them
properly at the very outset you won't
understand anything take that as given
okay you won't understand much but you
should be uh discussing with your
professor to get uh this thing
absolutely clear that what is the
overall story that he's expecting to
cover
okay like from the start to the end what
is the what is the overall idea here
okay he will invariably have some kind
of an idea okay try to make that
connection with
uh
your brain and the professor's brain so
if you're on the same page uh
you'll see you'll find the whole hole
going rather
i mean
i won't say easy but
it will ease your
transition from just an undergraduate
student to an undergraduate researcher
that's the point i want to make all
right
so
uh
at this stage you should be absolutely
clear by discussing with the professor
that if he wants you to reproduce the
results of that because many attempt
this is what is going to happen he will
want you to reproduce some of the
results of that of those papers
once you get that instruction launch
yourself hurt and soul into it this is
not the stage where you go about reading
stuff and generally learning stuff to
improve your knowledge no this is action
time on a mission mode try to reproduce
the results and this is the part where
there's various skill sets that you have
been developing in the previous stage of
your work that will start to pay
dividends okay i assure you you will
face like seemingly insurmountable uh
unsurmountable challenges uh
but i mean don't get flustered okay as
always i'm i'm saying again that
you have to have the courage
okay
plus always uh let's understand that
you're just reproducing the result okay
at this stage it has been done by other
people
they have done it you can also do it
okay maybe it will take a little bit
more time because you're inexperienced
but it can be done
okay so once this is done
now comes the most important thing
the actual project work meaning the
thing that you your professor wants you
to do
so this is the stage where many many
people flounder
okay so what are the challenges here the
challenge here is that
unlike course work
okay the question which is posed by the
professor does not necessarily have an
answer
okay it may have an answer it may not
have an answer what kind of answer even
the professor does not know and this is
the heart and soul of research work that
the
the most experienced person involved in
the research
does not know by definition of the
research work what is the answer
if
the answer is known then this is not
research work okay this is a fundamental
thing which many many
undergraduate students do not unders
understand okay or do not appreciate
okay you have to appreciate this the
answer is not no
okay
so
uh
so this is a peculiar kind of situation
so all your life you have been doing
problems for which the answer is always
there at the back of the book or it is
there in the teacher's head but this is
a situation where you are on your own
okay you may get help from phd students
or the from the seniors in the in the
professor's research group but
ultimately at the end of the day when
you are sitting down pen in hand or
computer in front of the computer you
are on your own
this is the part which is like a
like a shock to many many students
okay
sometimes they even think that the
professor is not guiding them properly
this is not true
okay it is supposed to be this this
abstract vague unknown thing you are
making your way into unchartered
territory okay so always always remember
this
uh i want to give an example here
that
you see
where do you find the hardest kind of
problems
okay so there can be some debates about
it but we can all appreciate the fact
that some of the hardest problems have
been posed in the international
mathematics olympiads okay
now
let's take the hardest problem of the
international mathematician like the
hardest ever in the history of
international mathematics olympia
even that problem
has a solution it's guaranteed that
there is a solution okay but your
research problem
may or may not have a solution okay that
is the challenge there
but the good thing is that
no matter how small no matter how humble
the research question it is
is it
it is your own it is your baby
okay if you figure it out if you nurture
it and if you develop it it is
completely your your thing your creation
okay this is a tremendous fulfillment
and happiness uh
associated with
nurturing and developing something so
creatively okay it's almost like
like artwork
okay like you have to actually i i
am not very being very good with my
words yet you have to actually
experience that joy of
seeing a an unknown thing through uh on
your own like the kind of satisfaction
the exhilaration it will find in your
heart that cannot be
described okay like that is why i say
that every undergraduate student should
do a little bit of research just to
experience that joy i'm sure there will
be many converts
who converts means who will uh start
thinking seriously about going for
higher studies if they once feel that
joy it's like an addiction
okay i
i don't know if i'm sharing this joy
with you sufficiently enough but it is
there okay it's almost like an addictive
joy
uh
so
uh
i think i have given you the the gist of
the matter here uh
there are certain logistical things to
keep in mind that once you have started
working in a professor's research group
as i said earlier maybe he'll put you in
touch with one of his phd students
but
that is only
to uh to guide you at some crucial
points uh maybe he's already experienced
in doing certain things and and take
take my word for it in certain kinds of
of a more ris mature research work uh if
there's a senior enough phd student
involved
he will probably know how to execute
some of the things much much better than
the professor so it's actually good
for you if if you're getting involved
with
discussing things with him
uh
uh just remember that uh
you should take his help the phd
student's help of the in the group uh
you should take the help of the
professor uh you should always always
keep him updated i know certain students
who are
who can take up challenges who are
extremely intellectually capable
academically serious but what happens is
that once they get this kind of a
challenge they take it on their ego that
i will i will not show my face to my
professor unless i can solve this
problem it's not like that it's like
almost like a collaborative give and
take kind of experience
that you have with the professor discuss
with him
and tell him about the roadblocks you
are facing
but on the opposite end of the spectrum
uh you shouldn't do this too much
because as i said earlier it is your
baby you have to nurture it
okay so at every roadblock that you face
try to surmount it on your own before
running to your professor
okay
most of the times you will not have the
answer directly he can always give you
certain pointers but ultimately you have
to figure it out
okay
so
if there is one thing that you need to
take away or maybe a couple of things
you need to take away from this
video is that first of all courage
and second is that you
must must appreciate that you are on
your own you have to uh
get the things done on your own
okay so
uh
as we say in kgp parlance
uh you have to do this with a lot of
tempo all right thank you very much and
all the best if you're embarking on this
wonderful and exciting journey of
undergraduate research thank you very
much